[Musique]
salut à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8 sport
sur tv et 78 nous sommes le lundi 22
octobre vous le voyez je ne suis pas
miquel et demi d'euros mais je vais
quand même vous présenter cette émission
tout de suite le sommaire la première
manche de coupe du monde de cyclisme sur
piste se dérouler tout le week end au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
un deal en utiliser côté français avec
trois médailles que retenir de ce rendez
vous on fait le point en plateau avec
notre consultant cyclisme jan dujarrier
c'est au rendez vous de ces chaque année
au rendez vous de l'automne à elancourt
le tournoi de handball des petits élans
étaient au programme au palais des
sports dix équipes y ont participé avec
des jeunes de 7 et 8 ans qui participait
pour la plupart à leur première
rencontre officielle dans la discipline
et puis jument 13 avant la route du rhum
entre saint-malo et la guadeloupe parmi
les participants cette année louis
burton skipper originaire de rambouillet
vise le top 5 dans la compétition de vol
entretien à la fin de ce magazine
déjà quelques cheat sur ce plateau mon
invité dans cette émission il ya une du
jir du bosphore wings est le consultant
à cyclisme de tv 60 18 alors ce week-end
soutenait la première manche de la coupe
du monde de cyclisme sur piste au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
on va y revenir dans un instant avec
vous une manche est difficile pour les
français en trois jours de compétition
trois médailles et quelques déceptions
retour sur l'événement avec nicolas
d'ambri et mélanie poquet et ben non
et bien non mathilde de s'y retrouver
une première à la maison difficile pour
mathilde de gros la championne d'europe
de kerhinet éliminé de sa discipline
phare elle échoue en demi finale de
l'épreuve après une quatrième place au
sprint pour
votre bilan ges plutôt prendre les
points positifs
regardez toutes les erreurs tactiques
que j'ai fait pour pouvoir aller mettre
en oeuvre enfin voilà justement ne pas
faire les mêmes erreurs dans une semaine
à toronto
les pistards français termine sept
manches avec trois médailles l'argent
pour le trio baugé vigier d'almeida en
vitesse par équipes et le bronze pour
adrien garrel au scratch et benjamin
thomas sur l'omnium
on va retenir le positif voilà le pour
petit personnel la troisième place sur
l'omnium
hier j'ai eu des grandes sensations
voilà c'est
ça faisait longtemps que j'avais pas
j'avais pas vibrer avec le public et
c'était vraiment un grand moment et on
voit là on avait ça fait du bien d'avoir
des compétitions en france chez nous
quelques
quelques regrets on était à domicile on
espérait
peut-être avoir des résultats des
meilleurs résultats on a tenté
du genre de nos sportifs sont sortis
assez rapidement
dans les manches de qualification donc
quelques regrets là on est rentré dans
la sélection olympique
qui va nous emmener à tokyo il ya 16
manches la première c'était championnat
d'europe là c'est la deuxième et on se
qualifie sur les épreuves par équipes
prochaine échéance pour le clan français
en fin de semaine la deuxième manche de
coupe du monde se tient du 26 au 28
octobre
hamilton au canada trois médailles
obtenues donc y ait sur cette première
manche de coupe du monde quel bilan on
vous tire est ce que comme le directeur
le directeur technique national vous
avez quelques déceptions ou des
satisfactions au contraire c'est vrai
que le bilan n'est pas n'est pas
flamboyant
quand on est à domicile comme un crack
en cours à domicile on rêve tous de
briller et il les avait tous envie de
briller
maintenant ça c'est ça c'est quand même
vraiment joué à beaucoup de petits
détails
une concurrence aussi qui était qui
était très très
très avec un conflit avait beaucoup q
rentrée avec des niveaux très retrait
relevé une entente avant cette émission
en termes de chronos on était sur des
très grandes performances grande
performance la vraie zen
le hollandais qui fait un chrono
meilleur que celui de jason kenny lors
des jeux olympiques de rio c'est moi
quand j'ai entendu neuf 9 44 vraiment
j'ai vu que c'était c'est fou quoi c'est
vraiment énorme
sébastien léger qui fait de 9.6 j'ai
discuté avec lui il disait que il
espérait encore aller plus vite il était
un petit peu déçue de son degré de son
chrono il s'est fait éliminer parce
qu'il s'est fait disqualifier par par
les juges sur une erreur qui ne mérite
pas du tout une déçue disqualification
mathilde se faire retirer aussi les deux
bronzes vraiment bien gagner sur une
décision arbitrale et il était elle
partait au protocole pour aller chercher
la médaille
une demi heure après on leur dit non non
la course à la coupe font refaire une
troisième manche vous êtes disqualifié
donc elle était plus du tout dans le
match difficile de se reconcentrer
je vois là c'est plein de petits détails
des décisions arbitrales qui n'ont pas
été en faveur des faveurs des français
peut-être une pression aussi qui a été
un peu malheureux malzieu à domicile
sessad évolue à domicile tout à fait
pascale jeuland par exemple sur sur
l'omnium m'inquiétais pas dans la course
mais sur l'omnium sur l'élimination je
trouve qu'il a fait une erreur à vouloir
passer passer à l'intérieur alors qu'ils
avaient pas de panique au moment de le
faire il y avait donc voilà peut-être un
petit peu de panique sur sur certaines
choses sur certaines prises de décision
mais voilà ils sont encore dire quand
même le président lice dès le week-end
prochain au canada et ils sont au niveau
physiquement ils sont là donc ça va ça
va ça va fleurir par la suite et ils
iront chercher les points des ions
chercher les qualifs pour être pour être
pour être à jeu au jeu au japon
sans oublier puis voilà après mois pour
moi la grosse satisfaction c'est de voir
un grégory baugé qui nous fait un 17
points 4 sur le premier tour de vitesse
par équipes 2 et 3 ans qui participait
pas à la coupe du monde ça faisait ça
faisait un moment qu'il n'avait pas fait
des temps aussi aussi bon voilà il ya eu
un bon gars pas un bon gars pas en avant
ben pour moi ça c'est une belle belle
satisfaction bourget qui se relance est
ce que c'est pas peut-être la fin d'un
françois pervis sept fois champion du
monde qu'il a a été éliminée dès les
phases de qualification et en demi
finales dont il a fait en effet dans le
viseur des finales de karine sur
demi-finale en keirin pour la finale de
can fille juste bon c'est pareil se joue
à pas grand-chose il a
et je vois que je me souviens bien delà
de cette finale
il fait peut-être l'effort au mauvais
moment et voilà et c'est pareil s'il
attend un petit peu plus basse et c'est
bon donc c'est du réglage mais moi je
trouve que les gars je trouve que les
gars et les filles sont sont là en ce
moment et physiquement sans l'avouer je
suis dernière chose donc les voulait dit
les jeux de tokyo cédant deux ans à
brooke à tokyo forcément au japon du
coup pas de pas d'inquiétude pad équipe
à reconstruire on a foré dans le bois le
seul bémol que je mettrais c'est quand
même sur mathilde je trouve que lui a
fait faire les trois épreuves sur trois
jours elle a 19 ans elle a que 19 ans
c'était un peu beaucoup
voilà bien sûr qu'elle courait à
domicile il faut qu'elle soit là parce
qu'elle brille au niveau international
maintenant c'était un petit peu beaucoup
faire une alternance avec avec sandie
clair sur certaines épreuves sera pu
être être un peu plus intelligent ou un
peu peut être intelligent de la part des
sélectionneurs
c'est mon seul mon seul bémol sur pour
tous les pouvoirs et la transition est
toute faite qu'elle dujarrier puisque
pour sa première compétition au
vélodrome national jeunes pistards de
l'équipe de france mathilde gros a pu
compter sur le soutien de sa famille et
de ses amis un malgré des résultats en
demi teinte durant les trois jours de
cette première manche de coupe du monde
cette famille a mis l'ambiance au bord
de la piste un reportage de nicolas
landry ils sont tous là pour enflammer
le vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines
dans le clan de mathilde gros vous avez
le papa maurice la maman séverine les
tentes et les amis ils viennent de toute
la france pour soutenir la jeune fille
star de 19 ans le lendemain de sa
quatrième place en vitesse individuelle
c'est vrai qu'hier soir elle était
extrêmement déçu
bon on a on s'est tous retrouvés pour
manger ensemble pour dîner ensemble le
soir on était une bonne cinquantaine et
donc elle est quand même passé
donc elle avait digéré sa déception et
elle est repartie pour pour faire le
maximum aujourd'hui et honorer son
maillot de champion d'europe
un titre remporté lors des championnats
d'europe de glasgow en août dernier
concentré à l'échauffement elle part
déterminée pour l'épreuve du keirin
devant le regard tendu de sa famille ils
sont à fond et encore si vous avez vu
mes grands parents vous avez dû les voir
aussi peint des fois ils avouent ils
disent non et mal à quoi surtout en
keirin en vitesse et riquet de la
pression mais un peu moins de chance de
chute donc ouais franchement à evreux
aussi ils dînent en fait on vit le truc
avec toi quoi donc c'est énorme
entre tension et encouragements la
famille gros mais l'ambiance au bord de
la piste ils sont fiers de leur petit
dans la petite finale dans certains cas
nous a fait plaisir est là aussi je
pensais ce qu'est plaisir parce qu'elle
a été déçu de pas aller en grande finale
mais bon c'est comédie
ça fait partie de son apprentissage et
après ben en fait elle apprend et de la
halle retient ce qu'il faut retenir et à
l'avance de plus en plus vite
je m'en suis déjà niveau mondial finir
quatrièmes en vitesse individuelle
huitième au kirin je veux dire il ya
trois ans
l'était pas à ce niveau là et là au fur
à mesure elle monte voilà donc c'est que
du bonheur foraine
moi tout ce que je retienne c'est
qu'elle rentre terme le carré et 4
vraiment contente
magnifique quoirin et ça c'est pour elle
c
chez les bus c'est bien
pour la jeune prodige de la piste
originaire du nord la progression est à
l'horizon
elle pourra toujours compter sur sa
ch'tite grande famille pour un jour
tutoyer le monde
en gros alors vouliez corriger quelque
chose et pas du tout originaire du nord
il est originaire du sud de la france je
sais plus quel petit village dans le sud
de la france mais c'est sud de la france
mattyb c est corrigé alors à l'image de
la famille de mathilde gros qui étaient
présentes en nombre au vélodrome
est-ce que vous allez sentir vélodrome
plein y avait 3000 supporters environ
par jour qui était qui étaient présents
à ce que franchement c'était
satisfaisant de ce côté vu la faible
communication qui a été mise en place
par par la fédération je suis
agréablement surpris par le résultat
voilà j'avais j'avais vraiment des
craintes et il ya de ça un mois je
disais mais on n'entend pas parler alors
oui bien sûr il y avait la ryder cup
mais c'est pas c'est pas la fédération
française qui est pénalisé par la razer
4 voilà on n'avait pas nous passer de
d'information là dessus voilà il y avait
une belle ambiance hier vendredi c'est
un petit peu calme ben voilà les gens
travaillent un tout simplement départs
en vacances aussi donc c'était un peu
compliqué mais ça que samedi et dimanche
avait vraiment du monde c'était bien et
moi je me mets complètement à la place
de de cette famille de la famille de
mathilde de gros parce que sont des gens
qui ya quatre ans il savait pas ce que
c'était le cyclisme et c'est le cyclisme
sur piste encore moins et voilà
découvrir ces épreuves et ses épreuves
de vitesse qui sont les épreuves reines
du cyclisme sur piste et leur fille ou
leur petite fille qui brille dans ces
épreuves là mais c'est juste génial et
je peux comprendre aussi la peur qui
peuvent avoir parce que ben on a vu la
belle championne du monde qui prend une
belle gamelle hier en finale juste à
l'arrivée mais voilà ça arrive très
régulièrement
y a pas de gros bobos c'est pas assez
pas grave mais ça que c'est toujours
spectaculaire mais les chutes sur piste
il y as autant que lui à moins de futurs
puits ce qui peut y en avoir sur route
un faux-pas faut pas dénigrer la piste
mais c'est vrai que c'est toujours plus
spectaculaires sur un sur la piste c'est
la première fois que le vélodrome a
accueilli le manche de coupe du monde de
cyclisme sur piste est ce que c'est un
événement à recevoir à nouveau et bien
vu l'engouement a vu le spectacle qui a
été fournie oui j'espère qu'on en aura
d'autres et et j'espère que la fédé va
pouvoir se permettre d'en faire d'autres
parce que bon faut pas oublier que les
comptes de la fédé ne sont quand même
pas au beau fixe
alors levé leurs hommes captées en tout
cas aux athlètes présents écoutez à ce
propos une pistarde italienne interrogée
par nicolas landry également la ministre
des sports qui était au déplacement en
déplacement au vélodrome samedi une
belle répétition d'organiser des coupes
du monde et championnats du monde chez
nous en france dans cette installation
la fédération y faire aussi ses larmes
en tant qu'organisateurs et bien sûr les
territoires qui sont aussi présentes
les élus qui pour voir aussi de quoi il
s'agit parce que prendre des décisions
en connaissance de cause c'est toujours
l'aspect targue aussi et je ne
m'imaginais pas comme ça qu'il est
vraiment très beau je souhaite bonne
chance au vélodrome pour les jeux
olympiques il accueillera celle que les
chais toulis mis à la casse et au
nouveau en europe à bloquer les
aéroports ça a été dit et évoquer les
ont été évoqués les jeux olympiques 2024
le vélodrome va accueillir des épreuves
de cyclisme sur piste c'est une bonne
répétition ce genre d'événement pour en
vue de saisir le bien sûr parce que ben
il faut pouvoir les bénévoles qui
participent il faut pouvoir aussi bien
les palais doit l'aider fidéliser et
puis ben qui connaissent leur rôle donc
bah oui ça c'est important
ensuite bas toutes les infrastructures
je veux dire moi ce vélodrome je le
connais je le pratique au quotidien
quand il est vide mais quand il est
rempli comme ça il ya il ya plein de
choses à gérer à gérer autour il ya
beaucoup de problématiques différentes
et qui s'ajoute donc il faut pouvoir les
gérer et si on veut que les jo se passe
idéalement et bien il faut que ça se
reproduise et de toute façon j'ai
réfléchi après enfin pendant leur
pendant l'interview on aura d'autres
épreuves puisque ben l'élever le don
servira de répétition pour pour les
jouets déjà une manche de coupe du monde
dès la saison prochaine
d'accord j'ai je suis pas sûr je pense
qu'en fin dans l'esprit de la coupe du
monde et lucie et bien faire de
l'alternance mais je pense qu'on aurait
dû signer d'ici deux ans ce serait très
bien merci
il ya sans charlie d'avoir été risques
je rappelle que vous êtes le consultant
cyclisme / sûreté des 78 on vous
retrouve notamment dans l'émission si on
parlait sport présentée par michael
ennemi doro du football le club de
plaisir dispose désormais de deux
nouveaux terrains synthétiques ils ont
été inaugurés samedi l'un d'eux sera
ouvert pour les jeunes de la ville
l'autre servira pour les entraînements
et matchs et des quelques 600 licenciés
plaisir waku total plus de 600000 euros
dont une subvention de 150 mille euros
par conseil départemental des yvelines
des terrains réalisées avec les derniers
standards en termes de revêtement et qui
doivent participer au développement du
club une équipe féminine a été créé le 9
aux plaisirs se fixe comme objectif de
retrouver lé division régionale chez les
masculins écouter ces quelques réactions
c'est important d'avoir un terrain à des
duels génération qui fait qu'ils amènent
qui amènent des nouveaux joueurs qui
amènent parce que c'est à dire les
parades de nouveaux jeunes qui sont
arrivés s'inscrire
oui c'est très important d'abord quand
même au niveau de l'image de marc
d'avoir un beau terrain la volonté de la
ville s'était également d'avoir un
terrain synthétique aussi ouvert pour
les enfants parce que il ya il ya celui
ci qui est pour le club particulièrement
mais aussi pour les scolaires et puis
nous avons un terrain synthétique sur
lequel nous nous sommes engagés auprès
des enfants pour qu'il soit ouvert en
permanence pour qu'ils puissent venir y
jouer et ça nous semble important pour
les enfants de toute la ville
[Musique]
allez quelques résultats à vous proposer
on continue avec du football la 5e
journée de championnat de régionale 3
qui se déroulait ce dimanche
aubergenville s'inclinent 2 buts à 1
contre boulogne billancourt à
l'extérieur la cbb qui est le leader au
classement l équipe réserve des mureaux
elle a obtenu un match nul 1 partout sur
la pelouse de parisi et match nul
également pour trappe dans le derby
yvelinois face au pecq trappe qui perd
par conséquent sa première place de
régionale 3 et donc est deuxième un
match important dans deux semaines à
venir pour les trappistes qui reçoivent
le troisième saint-ouen l'aumône et dans
le championnat de division 1 district la
6e journée plaisir l'emporté à
l'extérieur 2 à 1 contre mantois est
victoire également et sur le même score
mais à domicile pour guy en cours contre
hardricourt festival de buts enfin à
mort bas 4 buts à 4 contre sartrouville
prochaines journées au programme dans et
quinze jours on change de sport en rugby
avec plaisir décidément n'y arrive pas
dans le championnat de fédérale 2 une
nouvelle défaite dans la 6e journée
drancy sur sa pelouse
elle devance les plaisirs ou à d'une
courte tête 27 à 23 des yvelinois
peuvent tout de même se consoler avec le
point du bonus défensif plaisir est
dernier au classement de fédérale 2 le
basket avec la cinquième journée de
nationale 3 déconvenue à domicile pour
le fc trappes qui perd contre poitiers
score 77 à 68 les trappistes qui
joueront à nouveau dans quinze jours
enfin handball victoire de plaisir
plaisir après trois défaites d'affilée
succès 30 à 14 contre saint mandé dans
la cinquième journée de nationale 3
plaisir est ancré à la sixième position
de cette nationale 3 de handball en
balle toujours avec un tournoi organisé
ce dimanche au palais des sports d'el en
cours c'était la 13e édition du tournoi
des petits élans proposé par le club
d'elancourt maurepas est dix équipes
étaient en lice toute la journée c'est
un rendez vous pour la catégorie des
moins de 9 ans c'est à dire des enfants
âgés de 7 et 8 ans et qui débute dans le
sport les images de nicolas dendrite
ces enfants dispute pour la plupart leur
tout premier match de handball au club
d'elancourt maurepas la discipline se
pratique à partir de la catégorie des
moins de 9 ans et des jeunes de 7 et 8
ans le tournoi des petits élans et donc
une bonne occasion pour eux d'affronter
des adversaires du même âge c'est
vraiment le début de saison c'est des
jeunes qui viennent de découvrir
lamballe c'est leur première journée
finalement il n'ya pas il n'y a pas du
tout de championnat et tout s'est
vraiment il découvre la longue balle
ils sont en situation là ils se sont
entraînés depuis septembre ils ont
jamais eu de match officiel ce dimanche
21 octobre au palais des sports des
longs cours dix équipes des yvelines
étaient en lice pour le 13e tournoi des
petits élans et des clubs venus de
plaisir les clayes sous bois ou encore
ou dans les couleurs des maillots sont
différentes mais la stratégie ne varie
pas à 7 et 8 ans les enfants semblent
déjà avoir assimilé les codes de
l'esprit sportif et collectif
[Musique]
pavy machin le débat struth et parfois
son parcours et les manches près six
mois
sur des pages et bien défendre et de
jouer collectif
faire des passes de jouer en équipe
oh
laissez pas faire de courses chaque
armoire son joueur
on doit
m comme ça on pourra tenter d'attirer
sort injuste anti un treizième tournoi
des petits élans remportée par le club
de handball du perray-en-yvelines et je
vous propose à présent de prendre le
large dans cette émission le départ de
la route du rhum c'est la course de
voile entre saint-malo à la guadeloupe
sera donné le 4 novembre prochain parmi
les participants on retrouvera un
certain louis burton qui est originaire
de rambouillet le skipper veut terminer
dans le haut du classement sur son
bateau bureau vallée notre journaliste
michael et demi d'euros qui est absent
aujourd'hui mais que vous retrouver la
semaine prochaine
la rencontre est justement à paris à
propos de cette course à mes côtés lors
embolie teint louis burton qui
participera pour la troisième fois la
route du rhum
louis comment vous sentez vous à
quelques jours de prendre le départ
et ben écoute en pleine forme j'ai une
petite escale parisienne pour venir
faire des tests d'effort
la clinique ambroise paré il fait beau
on est au mois d'octobre
c'est un peu inquiétant pour le départ
parce que quand on a un été indien comme
ça en général il ya pas mal de
dépression qui commencent à s'enchaîner
à partir du mois de novembre mais mais
c'est pas forcément pour me déplaire
puisque le bateau bureau vallée est prêt
à partir et moi en pleine forme donc
voilà donc vous avez fait ces tests à
l'effort est ce que c'est nécessaire de
les faire ces tests obligatoires même
c'est une obligation de la part des
organisateurs de courses
il sert à vérifier si les concurrents
pas de problèmes cardiaques et s'ils
sont capables d'assumer un dépassement
de soi qu oblige la voile et surtout sur
une route du rhum on a on va être 125
concurrent le plus jeune à 24 ans le
plus le doyen à 70 ans avec des amateurs
des pros des gens qui régatent
régulièrement d'autres qui font ça que
de temps en temps
donc c'est important parce que sur
certaines routes du rhum il ya eu des
hélitreuillages à peu près à chaque
édition de personnes qui avaient des
problèmes cardiaques etc
donc ça permet de se rassurer ça permet
aussi de savoir en tant que sportif où
on en est donc je le disais précédemment
ça sera votre troisième participation
cette route du rhum troisième
participation j'ai fini 20e en 2010 5e
en 2014
cette année c'est la victoire que vous
visez j'ai un super bateau on a racheté
le bateau qui a gagné le dernier vendée
globe dans la catégorie imoca
on a grâce à nos partenaires purent
faire pas mal de voile qui vont être
tout neuf pour le départ de la route du
rhum et puis bal équipe bis racing qui a
préparé le bateau toute l'année moi j'ai
beaucoup navigué dessus maintenant il ya
un plateau de dengue puisqu'il y aura 21
bateaux dans ma catégorie et dans l'es5
ce serait pas mal un podium ce serait ce
serait une belle réussite est alors la
victoire on n'en parle pas ou est ce
bateau sera t'il performant alors c'est
un bateau qui est très performant il
n'est pas de la dernière génération
puisqu'il ya des nouveaux bateaux qui
sortent là il y en aura 1 sur le départ
de la route du rhum celui de jérémie
beyou mais il fait partie des six sept
bateaux à foil qui sont très aboutis
très performant et qui ont un vendée
globe dans les pattes donc qui ont fait
preuve de fiabilité
il faut pas oublier que pour pour faire
un résultat sur une transat en course il
faut d'abord arriver il ya souvent
beaucoup d'abandons voilà j'espère que
je serai dans ceux qui arriveront est
évidemment le plus vite possible puisque
c'est l'objectif mais qu'est ce que ça
représente pour un skipper la route du
rhum c'est une course vraiment mythique
c'est c'est la course qui nous a bercés
tous depuis qu'on est tout petit c'est
la course qui a été lancé pour contrer
les courses qui était organisée par les
anglais dans les années 60 où ils ont
décidé de réduire la taille des bateaux
alors que tous les français qui courait
à l'époque avec des bateaux gigantesques
ils ont décidé de réduire à 16 mètres et
donc à une poignée de français qui s'est
mis ensemble pour créer une course un
peu nos limites et il ya eu lors de
cette course là en soixante dix huit sur
la première édition 98 secondes entre le
premier et le deuxième
et après à chaque édition des choses
incroyables
enfin pas tous les citer mais la
victoire de florence arthaud la première
grande victoire en course au large d'une
femme en 90 les doublés de laurent
bourgnon ça a toujours été un terrain de
développement de technologies qu'avec
les multicoques les orma et puis
maintenant les imoca à foil et puis les
ultimes qui volent nos limites des
bateaux qui font 33 m quelle est la
différence entre une vendée globe est
une route du rhum
quelle est la différence 6 on n'est plus
dans le sprint alors tout à fait en fait
le
le vendée globe c'est une course qui
dure entre 75 et 100 jours pour le
premier et le dernier est donc on est
obligé de rentrer dans un rythme
physique et physiologique qui permet de
tenir sur cette durée là on est obligé
de dormir un peu plus on est obligé de
s'alimenter de manière plus régulière
sur la route du rhum c'est en trois
phases le départ la sortie de la manche
où il ya énormément de concurrents il ya
des plaisanciers il ya des pêcheurs il
ya des cargos on peut pas dormir jusqu'à
ce qu'on soit libéré après huit ans à la
pointe gauche de la france et puis
ensuite on a en général a passé 2 3 des
pressions sur lesquels on dans
lesquelles on se fait pas mal taper
dessus et après derrière c'est un sprint
dans l'alizé avec un vent qui établit le
soleil qui commence à nous réchauffer
les poissons volants etc et il faut pas
se déconcentrer parce que ça se joue
avec des empannages le vent passe d'un
côté de l'autre et il faut tirer les
bons bords pour arriver devant est il
arrivé en guadeloupe basséen pour
l'avoir vécue deux fois une arrivée
complètement mythique un accueil génial
et les guadeloupéens qui nous réserve
toujours des belles surprises
il ya une stratégie qui a déjà été mise
en place du côté des bureaux vallée oui
oui il ya une stratégie parce que parce
qu'on veut avant tout arriver donc vous
prendre un départ j'ai toujours
l'habitude de prendre des départs un
petit peu incisif et là c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt partie relancer mais plutôt
en deuxième partie de ligne pour avoir
le temps d'éviter des bateaux qui serait
un peu à l'arrêt entre la ligne de
départ et puis le cap fréhel donc un
départ prudent et ensuite dès qu'on est
un petit peu en eau claire que les
différentes catégories sont mis en place
et qu'on est plus mélanger s'est attaqué
très fort pour rester dans le rythme du
groupe de tête justement pour passer ces
fameuses dépression est arrivé dans
l'alizé
dans le groupe des 5 6 quand on arrive
dans l'alizé on n'est pas devant surtout
avec un plateau aussi fort que celui ci
c'est très difficile de pouvoir jouer
devant vous avez participé à de
nombreuses compétitions sur sur mer
vendée globe
tout ce type de compétition est ce que
vous sentez un peu plus attendu
peut-être qu'avant parce que vous vous
sentez quand vous arrivez sur sur le
port au départ oui je commence à je
commence à ressentir un petit peu ça
parce que ça fait 8 ans 9 ans maintenant
que je cours tous les ans avec un
partenaire fidèle et c'est rare on
commence à faire partie des ddd bateaux
qui sont là depuis longtemps
il ya quand même quelques quelques types
que j'ai réussi à mettre derrière donc
forcément ils m'attendent
et puis
on commence aussi à bien se connaître et
puis j'ai un super bateau donc forcément
ça augmente le potentiel de chance
d'avoir une bonne machine comme ça c'est
un sport mécanique
voilà mais bon ça reste très très très
fraternel et puis 1 puis c'est comme
dans tout il ya des gens avec qui on
s'entend bien d'autres avec qui on
s'entend moins bien donc sur les départs
on va avec les potes on va pas avec avec
les personnes qu'on n'aime pas la
question qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter sur cette traversée a mené
bureau vallée de l'autre côté et puis et
puis pourquoi pas monter sur le podium
en guadeloupe on le souhaite en tout cas
merci louis burton
le départ de cette route du rhum ce sera
le 4 novembre prochain de saint malo
[Musique]
un seul agent d avant de se quitter pas
beaucoup de rencontres sportives en ces
vacances de la toussaint
cet agenda c'est du rugby la 7e journée
du championnat de fédérale 2 plaisir
accueille le paris université club ce
dimanche à 15 heures c'est au stade
robert barran et je vous le disais tout
à l'heure lé plaisir oise sont en très
mauvaise posture dernier au classement
une victoire est donc nécessaire face au
7e ex-aequo de cette fédérale 2 voilà
c'est la fin de ce sept huit sports
belle semaine sportive avec tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il